[Música]
[Aplausos]
mientras más otra vez se les rodea
la verdad es que yo nunca fui buena para
las ciencias exactas y aquel día después
de que el profesor dijera mi nombre y
pensara que iba a ser también en las
matemáticas como mi hermano mi vida
cambió cambió a mal mi seguridad mi
esencia lo que yo pensé que era se
desbordó ese día después de leer mi
nombre
la unesco dice que la inclusión
educativa es implementar cambios en los
contenidos y ajustes en las evaluaciones
de los profesores y de los chicos cuando
en realidad es tener un acercamiento
diferente a cada una de las personas sin
importar sus necesidades sus capacidades
o sus intereses con esto garantizar que
todos tendrán una educación de calidad
para las escuelas sin embargo a una
inclusión no está consolidada la
inclusión para las escuelas en muchas
ocasiones es aceptar a personas de todos
los perfiles pero hacer algunos cambios
muy muy pequeños para no bajar el nivel
educativo en el aula cuando la inclusión
es abrir las puertas al diálogo es abrir
las puertas a la diversidad al más
preciado de los recursos para cualquier
profesor para que al relacionarse con
las otras experiencias se genere un
talento
para mí la inclusión entonces es
explotar los talentos de cada una de las
personas en el aula es permitirles que
se relacionen para que se genere un
ambiente de reconocimiento que en poco o
mucho nivel es necesario para sentirnos
parte de cualquier comunidad
en 1990 michael jordan ubican a michael
jordan y era considerado el mejor
jugador de baloncesto del planeta pero
no fue hasta que involucró los
conocimientos y los talentos de todos
sus compañeros que logró ser reconocido
y tener un campeonato mundial
ken robinson habla en su libro el
elemento describiéndolo como el punto
donde convergen las aptitudes naturales
con la inclinación personal y dice que
cuando alguien se encuentra en el
elemento ha encontrado la mitad de su
identidad ha encontrado lo que va a
hacer el resto de su vida conviene estar
en el 2016 mi sobrino fue diagnosticado
con un problema de aprendizaje para mí
como psicóloga y persona era difícil
entender que una persona con tantas
habilidades con tanta inteligencia
podría tener un problema para aprender
sin embargo gracias a un buen
diagnóstico ya una escuela sobre todo
que le regreso
y le explotó los talentos daniel pudo
generar otra vez la lectoescritura y no
sólo eso hoy es cinta negra o nada toca
dos instrumentos
quiero compartirles tres maneras de
generar inclusión en el aula
la inclusión y quiero recordarles a
todos es para todos no solamente para
grupos específicos la inclusión es para
todas las personas en el aula el
reconocimiento y la validación de los
logros son indispensables para sentirnos
parte de un grupo es parte de sentirnos
incluidos sin importar la clase que
imparta como profesor dedica tiempo a la
empatía y a la tolerancia
vamos a utilizar
[Música]
y si el día de hoy estoy más presente
que nunca porque aunque sé que nunca he
sido buena en las ciencias exactas hoy
sé que las fortalezas y las habilidades
que tengo están fuera de esa burbuja y
están explotadas fuera de esa burbuja
quiero dejarlos con una frase y quiero
invitarlos a que explotemos talentos
después de esto las diferencias están en
las visiones comunes pero la relación
entre las almas solo en los seres
sensibles muchas gracias
[Aplausos]